foreign
next we got Jack in Grand Rapids hey
Jack welcome to the show
thanks guys how you doing we're doing
great how can we help
all right so I have a question about the
I guess the morality of my job so what
do you do man person I'm a car sales
person
you're a murderer
what I was hoping you were gonna say
okay yeah sorry it's not as interesting
to me as you hope um yeah so obviously
huge part of my job is signing people up
for car loans
um which ever since listening to you
guys I don't
I don't entirely agree with I don't
think it's the right path and I I kind
of feel bad for customers at the same
time I know it's you know my duty uh to
do that so I'm just I've been struggling
a little bit with kind of the moral
responsibility of that I know I'm not
the one signing them up I'm not the
finance person but you know I know
what's happening I know what's happening
so I'm gonna go in the office and just
something I've been dealing with I'm
giving advice of you know am I more
responsible for that should I be seeking
some other work because this job hasn't
been a big blessing for my family so
just maybe seeking some guidance with
that I think every Everybody I've ever
met has a moment when they
walk by the mirror and look in it and
ask himself is the job they're doing or
the people they're working for or the
culture of their job or the time away
from family that has some sort of value
misalignment and they have to ask
themselves is this okay with me and so
what I would tell you is I've got my
personal opinion I think it's way more
valuable for you to make that choice and
it sounds like you've made that choice
you just realize like and I go back to
people who and again this isn't about
the facts or anti-vaxx but people were
told to keep your job you will get this
vaccination and some said okay and some
said I'm gonna forgo my
paycheck because I'm not doing this
um often our values cost us something
and it sounds like your values you know
what you feel you don't feel good about
what you're doing and again I've got
people working who I love who in the car
industry so that's not that's why I'm
not putting it put it out there but for
you
you're having a harder time looking in
the mirror and so I would tell you
um
go with your guts what your values are
and then know that's probably going to
cost you something and it's not
something by the way you have to walk in
on on Monday and quit right it might be
something that you say this is not going
to be what I do the long-term play yeah
we've had many people Bankers they end
up doing this and like I just can't
anymore and here's the little two Jack
and we say this all the time that that
debt is not a sin right this is not a
Salvation issue this is not a thing that
like it's it's not you can have debt and
you know in the faith world still love
Jesus like go to heaven right like this
is not a Salvation issue but it is down
to a little bit of that moral dilemma
for yourself and how do you feel do you
feel good at them today and I think some
people can hold that and walk forward
and some people can't just out of a
personal conviction yeah we call those
people Psychopaths right I'm just
kidding I was like no no no no no no no
no no but but yeah it's it that's one of
those areas that's different for
everybody so yeah they can hold it
different ways right or am I a
psychopath maybe I mean I got a tick
tock account I do it every day like what
am I doing you're a YouTuber John trust
me I know all right this is the Ramsey
Show